ohne witz ich hab ein halb herzen ich
habe ein halb herzen ohne witz ohne
witze ohne witz oh mein gott ich war
aufgeregt oh mein gott gibt gas was ist
hier dass ein schwein mit einem mit
reduzieren ein
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft galaxy nachdem die erste
folge ja ein bisschen
ich will ich sagen an schränkt war wir
waren halt wirklich zu viel erwarten sie
waren geständig
viele menschen und jetzt sind wir wieder
in der altbekannten hashtag unproduktiv
konstellation ich habe einfach auch von
anfang an der cross und ich haben uns
hier ein galaxy jetzt erstmal darauf
konzentriert ein schönes haus zu finden
in der ersten folge nicht zu verrecken
alles mögliche während sonic einfach
irgendwo rum gelaufen ist und max direkt
eine spinne direkt eine fledermaus war
das ist zwar cool aber wir wollten uns
jetzt erst mal ein bisschen das ganze
ruhig angehen und danach angreifen
deswegen ich geh jetz auch mal auf den
server endlich drauf bevor ich hier zehn
jahre menü bin wie seine sache ist ja
auch das wort ich versuche irgendwie die
ganze zwischendurch mal einzustreuen ich
habe unglaublich boxer war mal wieder
auch so eine mischung wie hero eben
damals so am aus pvp und ich bau mir was
auf und ich habe wirklich viel zu
erforschen und ich glaube das kann zb
team auf jeden fall bieten als mopac
dass wir einfach schön durch die gegend
bauen können und gleichzeitig trotzdem
noch etwas erforschen und hin und wieder
eine das pvp gefecht haben das ist so
mein kleiner persönlicher wunsch für
dieses projekt deswegen könne
könnt ihr hier jetzt mal das nutzen um
wieder so wie üblich entspannt zu reden
ja genau deswegen ist oder die torqeedo
erste folge war zwar cool wir konnten
euch eine menge zeigen was wirklich ein
bisschen was ich dir einen angedachten
oha wer redet jetzt dies dass so ein
bisschen crazy
deswegen habe wir uns gedacht okay
vision gehen jetzt hier alleine kurz in
den komfort und die nächste folge wird
mit jemandem aus dem anderen team sein
hier haben wir schon mal verraten dass
er schaut euch auf jeden fall dinge zu
folgern und überlegter mal mit wem der
ist sogar gerade auf dem server mit wem
können wir wohl in der nächsten folge
ihr zusammen aufnehmen ich bin jetzt
gerade mal kurz unterwegs und wollten
wir hier irgendwie eisen zusammen
grabbeln
weil ich kann das jetzt übrigens auch
mal kurz kurz zeigen hier hat nämlich
gerade eine schwester tot ist lillian
piel ich weiß nicht wer in paris lyon
aber was ich gerade eben zeigen wollte
ist auch das worüber die ganze den
ersten folge geredet oder das wenn man
hier jemanden tötet dann kann man sich
in eine spinne verwandeln und natürlich
kann man sich auch wieder zurück mit q
kriegt man hier so die krasse auswahl
man kann sich natürlich tue es ihr total
geil er mit öl ist yahoo
das total der berner all das ist richtig
cool
und jetzt das wollte ich nicht in der
ersten folge sagen weil ich dazu gar
nichts kam
ich wollte nur ich sehe da hinten wer
ist das denn eine hexe oh mein gott ich
habe mich glaube ich auch eine hier ich
weiß nicht ob ich die töten soll
vielleicht probiere es nämlich mal aber
ich habe kaum aussicht sollte friesen
holen
ich wollte nämlich ganz kurz was fragen
hier meine tollen zuschauer wenn ich
ausscheide per click und ich klicke auf
no dann ist bei mir alles so dunkel
wisst ihr woran das liegt wenn ich
irgendwie shader rein packe sei es der
hier oder sei es auch irgendwie der hier
oder so kann ich packe mal wieder den
normalen rennen hatte linie dann ist das
halt wieder alles hält also könnt ihr
mir sagen woran es liegt dass wir auf
jeden fall super toll dankeschön niemand
drin ich habe einfach schon eine wohnung
gefunden obwohl niemand irgendwo ich
dachte bei der hexe drin und es wird
total spannend aber es war gar nicht so
ich weiß auch gar nicht aus welchem wie
ich das ganze noch die sein will ist ich
hab das einfach so spontan mal
beschlossen
ok ich wieder reden jetzt das ist das
neue industrie auch echt brauchst du
nicht auch essen braucht total essen ich
glaub ich nehme das wasser ja ich hatte
von anfang an auch ein paar äpfel im
inventar und vielleicht auch oder so bei
mir war es halt weniger wahrscheinlich
mache jetzt einfach mal direkt da oben
irgendwie eine kleine kleine fahren
damit wir nicht wieder dass es auch nur
gut fahren das ist dass das durch das
problem haben nichts an essen zu
besitzen und brot ist ein
grundnahrungsmittel was man muss einfach
diese samen mitnehmen ja du musst
einfach hier die die sachen die sachen
wegklatschen
dieses ist ein gras und da gibt es auch
hier mehrere sahen also ich habe sie zum
tomatoes sieht zum beispiel auch noch
oder coppens und strawberry es ist also
ähnlich dann das erinnert dann ja auch
wieder an hero und zwar war es ja da
auch so dass es bestimmte verschiedenes
gab zb konnten sie konzentriert an
wolle machen oder irgendwie sowas ich
brauche auch hier gerade wieder
aluminium ab ich nehme jetzt im
aluminium mit
guck mal da war ja weil in hero
aluminium war wichtig am ende weil man
mit sich damit was kann man sich extra
herzen
ich weiß noch nicht genau wie das ganze
jetzt aus take off the beaten wie das
ganze hier aussehen wird ich nehme das
mal als mit ihr könnt mir dann wieder
wie wir hier und die kommentare
schreiben bekommen das ist unwichtig das
ist und wichtig ist dass das ist wird es
so dass luca und ich vor allem aus wir
sind ja total prosieben de und dann
haben wir da ein bisschen aus zeitmangel
uns nicht im voraus informieren können
was aber auch ganz schön ist weil wir
wieder sehr frisch deckungs freudig zu
100 von jünglingen in dieses projekt
stürzen und entdeckungsfreudige durch
die gegend laufen das ist eigentlich
ganz cool so an sich und was ich auch
noch erwähnen wollte ich könnte mir
vorstellen das natürlich bei dieses
projekt jetzt auch so ein bisschen so
aus nichts gekommen ist dass vielleicht
einige von euch kann ja ich spreche
jetzt mal für die zukunft weil wir das
scala
wir nehmen das hier gerade am montag auf
das muss man einfach sagen
allerdings ich hab ja zornig von habe
angst dass nämlich in getötet sowie der
ersten folge drauf habe allerdings da
ihr die folge gerade am samstag sät kann
ich sagen dass am mittwoch schönen
ankündigungs video ksk ankündigung und
sowas dass das natürlich schon was ich
wusst ich hätte das mega lag weiß ich
was ich erwähnen wollte um das kurz
fertig zu führen war eigentlich dass wir
ja auch schon bei war damals ein video
gemacht haben wo es vielleicht um
gewisse fragen gehen und falls das hier
das müssen wir natürlich auch nicht
falls dem hier wieder der fall sein
sollte das vielleicht ein paar fragen
oder du bist ein kritikpunkt auftreten
dann kann man die uns gern in die kommen
schreiben und wir werden vielleicht
versuchen in einer der weiteren folge
eine kleine aufklärungs episode zu
machen damit ihr nicht komplett im
dunkeln steht das kennt ihr ja von uns
das wieder gerne auf zuschauer fragen
eingehen ja ja das war es eigentlich
schon vor sagen wollten ich werde jetzt
mal ganz kurz ich wollte eigentlich
eisen suchen ich finde aber keins du
findest kein reisen
ich bin in riesigen schlucht drin ich
habe gerade den schah verwandelt in ein
schaf in ein schaf und das ist mir auch
weil die sache man kann sich in der
dinge nur wissen wir was in vier losen
das straffe droppen muskeln und fleisch
muskeln muskeln ja ich hab grad muskeln
und das ist von dem add on mac home and
i plus also mikro und die chromatin
so ist okay das ist eine ganz tolle
ideen immer irgendwie ich bin ja auch in
unserem kleinen sandstrand und schon
jetzt ein paar kokosnüsse focus dass
wechsel
das wechselt soll ich das excel oder
soll ich sie ich weiß nicht ich verstehe
nicht wieso töten die sich denn da alle
das verstehe ich gar nicht ich will auch
an wasser und man kann kann ich mit dem
muskel essen dann kann ich essen
ich will einfach reisen was ich bin und
was ich finde ich meine ich könnte
könnte mir vorstellen dass kenntnisse
häuschen in scharf ich bin dass mörder
scharf
ich bin dass mörder scharf du kannst mit
richtig spannend jetzt bei mir leicht
mich sagte er das ist ja mal richtig
crazy gerade was hier abgeht das ist
echt ne ist macht einfach kein bisschen
leise nicht alle anderen so jakob bio
ich hab dir passt so georg 15k brücke
entfernt
ja was hat denn was hat denn was hat den
early bird im veranstalter keb getötet
oder wurde kämpfen was war was dabei
getötet irgendwann und ich weiß nicht
was das soll so vorher noch so ja nicht
töten aggressiv geworden unser kleiner
genom an weil der geile freundin im
urlaub mit der freundin ist name hallo
aber ich nehme jetzt einfach dieses
bamboo blog so ich habe auch direkt
jetzt jetzt kann ich mal gucken jetzt
greife ich die hexe mal als alles was
gerade ich sie an ich gehe mal als hexe
mögen bestimmt spinnen das hat
verwandelt sich in eine spinne ja und
macht einfach reisen dann gehe ich jetzt
gleich die hexe angreifen oliveira
bester vorne
also falls ihr euch wundert wieso man so
schnell ressourcen finde es ist so
ähnlich wie bei
hero also excel damals dass hier eben
nicht drin ist der gewisse erzählt von
anfang an sex ich weiß es nicht ich soll
ich solch die hexe attackieren ich hab
ein bisschen angst ich will nur einen
englischen verdammte scheiße finden
damit die hilfstruppen stopp stopp stopp
stopp ich hab sie ich hab sie einfach ab
ohne dass sie ein einziges mal auch nur
damage machen konnte und es kann nicht
ich hab commander krieger in spa phoenix
hast du nur angepasst ich will jetzt
auch ein schaf sein ich möchte euch
zeigen wie es ist wenn man ein schaf ist
auf den boden der tatsachen zurück ist
dann ist es wirklich mal scharf zu sein
das gibt einem auch schon ganz andere
leben ich bin ein schaf du ich bin voll
klein ja weg ich will keinen schaden
seiner sein lassen brunnen
es ist ein wunsch brunnen das hat man so
scheiße laufenden band zeuge irgendwie
dahinter sondern irgendwie so ein
kleiner strand auch nochmal mit einer
hütte ich will wieder mein körper zurück
ich hab' ich habe gerade ihnen dass das
gefühl luca meine nasenlöcher bilden
gerade ein schwarzes loch die weiten
sich immer so wenig erregten beim
spielen weißt du wie ich dann ist es
hier drin wo ich habe keine ahnung weil
ich auch kein shader drauf oder so also
ja ich will am liebsten auch kein schild
darauf einmal was ist bei mir dann
einfach unglaublich dunkel
ja es stimmt dass dabei gerade irgendwo
dieser bug am start das sei ja auch
gefragt wie sich das vielleicht
irgendwie anpassen oder ändern lässt ich
hätte zumal das haus wobei ich papier
also wir haben schon im wald leben
irgendwie viel mit shader unseren kam
deswegen dachte sich einfach mal
ich würde am liebsten auch kein fehler
drin haben aber es geht er irgendwie
nicht anders erzählte partie die die
schlechteste version heruntergeladen das
waren wieder menschen habe ich einfach
das problem immer wenn wir sagen lukas
sie mit einem techniker dann packt
irgendwelche iks hamster und youporn
links aus ist total komisch bei dem wenn
ich jetzt den zombie töte wintersaison
die hunde vergiftet ja alles was du tun
ich wachse wieder sagte war du kannst du
eigentlich direkt irgendwie zu so also
wie kann sich halt unterm ob sie
erschleichen ich bin nicht vergiftet
ziemlich konkret sollte man es aber
nicht tun war glaube ich eine regel ja
das könnte natürlich sein
wir werden wenn ihr irgendwelche frage
habt dann werden wir das jetzt noch mal
nachschauen weil wir auch keine ahnung
haben das schon wieder so eine hexe drin
machte wieder platt ihr ex in ihr könnt
mir gar nichts zu tun zu haben doch nur
um gezielte und jetzt bin ich eine bin
ich bin es süße hexel mit meinem schwert
ganz allein hier drin und das ist ein
pool h ich hoffe es zu essen was ist das
hier tomate sieht automaten zieht mensch
ich bin eine hexe und bin wunderschön
days auch ihre idee ist einfach beim vom
skelett getötet worden ja ich werde gar
nämlich auch ganz schön was hab ich den
preis gefunden
ich finde da hab ich finde lauda sachen
zumindest sie mich ja aber jetzt jetzt
jetzt ist es nämlich ganz praktisch wenn
ich jetzt durch wechsel schnell zu einer
spyder hat dann greift mich die mobs dem
ich glaube ich nicht mehr an und damit
kann ich den kiosk ans meer in die eisen
rüber schmeißen oder so wir sind dazu
nachbarn bis auf bis auf das skelett
eben ich erwarte ich bin ich bin nicht
gerade ocado gott oh gott oh gott oh
gott oh gott ich bin schon am sterben
ich bin richtig hart am sterben grad ich
bin richtig hart am sterben ohne bis
jetzt ohne witz ohne wird sich ab
eineinhalb herzen ich hab ein halb
herzen ohne witz ohne witz ohne witz so
mein gott bin ich gerade aufgeregt oh
mein gott gibt gas was ist hier dass ein
schwein mit einem mit reduzieren ein
was ist das eigentlich für glocken sie
nicht schön aus die sind immer so
scheiße aus ich habe all meine alles
verloren es für dich so hässlich findet
ihr durch die gegend rennt was ist das
55 blöder abfahrt wer sich abholen jetzt
gefordert oder so man leute das ist doch
das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein man das
kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein dass jetzt
natürlich beleidigt gerade nicht dieses
projekt sondern ja natürlich ich reg
mich über meine skills auf das doch ist
doch logisch dass ich das aber weiß ich
dachte hey ich fahre nämlich ist eine
spinne
das problem ist da hat mich halt schon
hatte mich schon in skelett als mensch
gesehen ja und auch eine spinne und
diese
daher und die spiele hab ich dann
irgendwie dann gekriegt aber natürlich
noch ein fall bekommen und das war echt
cool irgendwie ich weiß auch gar nicht
ob das geht dass man sich wirklich dann
unter die monster komplett runter mischt
oder so aha so ein käse ja kann ich
jetzt gefordert uns allein mit 0 1
verlor
auch so was mache ich denn jetzt ist es
nacht und ich will jetzt nicht bei
nachdem die rausgehen ich brauch was zu
fressen
ach man krasser kassel also dafür da bin
ich will ich einfach direkt das hat
wirklich also bei hero bin ich in der
ersten folge gestorben das dahin ist
übrigens unsere basis die wunderschön
ich finde ich jetzt fertig gleich noch
mal ich mach dich minimap so ein
bisschen hirn deutschen sport exercise
komme ich manchmal ein bisschen kleiner
stirbt gleich wieder schön dass sie
gleich wie kleiner das ist wundervoll
das kann ja noch einstellen was ist hier
jetzt schon wieder los das ist schon
wieder irgendwelche hexen die
koordinaten noch ein bisschen größer
du kannst du dich bitte mal zumindest
seelisch um mich kümmern oder so geht
das ich liebe dich danke schön einfach
nur so ein bisschen überall bin ich ein
huhn kann ich also tun kann ich doch ein
bisschen flattern
man fängt immer noch scheiße wie diese
ist in münchen fleisch ich bin da schon
tot
ernsthaft ich bin jetzt da ich schon
wieder tot wenn die folge senden
auch carlos kandidaten was suchst du ja
eigentlich habe ich ja schon wieder
aluminium ohr alter in hero in der
ersten folge bleibt also zweimal
gestorben
von einem bären getötet werden wird tut
ja leute jetzt jetzt darf ich auch nicht
mehr auf den server darauf habe ich
glaube ich guck dir mal kurz auf dem
teilweise ich glaube wir sind ja wir
sind gleich mit der folge durch das
heißt auch luca darf bald seine beenden
ich gelobe natürlich das ist doof
gelaufen
sagen wir es mal so groß wie läuft denn
das jetzt ab mit deinen uploads wie dass
wir das ding jetzt applaus der punkt ist
morgen kann bei mir keine folge kommen
ich werde versuchen eigentlich galaxy so
gut es geht täglich zu bringen ja immer
wieder mit der angst das kennt ihr ja
von mir mittags 15 uhr ist meist dass
minecraft zeit und morgen kann dann
logischerweise keine kommt das heißt die
schau dir doch einfach bei irgendwem
anders zb unnötig liegt ja nahe dass man
dann beim coni schaut und jetzt durfte
ich natürlich fleißig in den kommentaren
darüber aus dass sind die unglaublich
gespielt ich bin ein richtiger richtiger
überlebenskünstlerin das habe ich in
bayern schon bewiesen das habe ich diego
gewesen und in jedem minecraft projekt
welches und jetzt beweisen wir auch dass
wir uns super an die regeln halten weil
sie an 14 minuten 40 um und ich würde
sagen es euch gefallen als bewährt und
da wir sehen uns morgen wieder bei cdos
nicht aber bei mir